>> AFTER THE RELEASE OF
THAT AFFIDAVIT I SAT DOWN AND
SPOKE WITH STEVE GONCALVES, HE
IS THE FATHER OF ONE OF THE
VICTIMS, KAYLEE GONCALVES.
HE WAS DEFIANT, STILL GRIEVING.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID IT WAS LIKE
TO SEE THE SUSPECT IN COURT
FACE-TO-FACE.
>> STEVE, YOU KNOW, THERE'S SO
MUCH OF WHAT HAS TO BE JUST
UPSETTING INFORMATION SEEING
THIS ARREST AFFIDAVIT NOW.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS, AS ALWAYS,
JUST HOW ARE YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
DOING?
>> WELL, IT'S A BIT OF A
NARRATIVE CHANGE.
YOU GO FROM HUNTING, HUNTING,
LOOKING, POKING, LIKE YOU ALWAYS
SEE THESE SHOWS WHERE IT'S
SOMEBODY THAT YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY
CLOSE, SOMEBODY YOU TRUST.
I HAD A HARD TIME WITH THAT
BECAUSE KAYLEE WAS SO KIND TO
PEOPLE.
SHE WAS ORNERY TO HER BROTHERS
AND SISTERS, BUT FOR ALL
OUTWARDS APPEARANCES SHE WAS A
VERY, VERY NICE PERSON.
WE WERE PUZZLED BY, YOU KNOW --
WE JUST WOULDN'T -- WEREN'T
READY FOR A BULLY STORY OR
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES.
SO YOU READ THE AFFIDAVIT AND
YOU JUST FIND OUT THAT NOBODY
UNDERSTANDS EXACTLY WHY, BUT HE
WAS STALKING THEM, HE WAS
HUNTING THEM, HE WAS JUST A
PERSON LOOKING FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY AND IT JUST HAPPENED
TO BE IN THAT HOUSE.
IT'S HARD TO TAKE.
IT'S VERY HARD TO TAKE.
YOU KNOW, I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE,
I THOUGHT MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE
PUT HER IN SOME GUN SAFETY
COURSES, HAVE DONE SOMETHING,
BUT SHE HAD HER PHONE RIGHT NEXT
TO HER AND SHE COULDN'T CALL
911, SO THESE WERE JUST GIRLS
THAT WENT TO SLEEP THAT NIGHT
AND A COWARD, YOU KNOW, HUNTER
THAT WENT OUT AND HE PICKED HIS
LITTLE OPPONENT THAT WAS GIRLS
AND THAT'S PROBABLY WHY THE
HOUSE WAS TARGETED WAS BECAUSE
THERE WAS JUST GIRLS THERE AND
IT ENDED UP BEING A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF A DIFFERENT CHALLENGE,
DIFFERENT INSTANCE, HE WASN'T
PREPARED FOR, BUT I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE AFFIDAVIT SHOWS IS
SOMEBODY WHO WAS STALKING THE
HOUSE.
>> GOODNESS.
YEAH, THAT'S ONE THING THAT
STOOD OUT TO ME, THE IDEA THAT
HIS CELLPHONE INFORMATION SHOWED
HE HAD BEEN IN THE AREA OF THE
HOUSE AT LEAST 12 TIMES BEFORE.
DO YOU BELIEVE KOHBERGER WAS
STALKING YOUR DAUGHTER IN
PARTICULAR OR JUST THE HOUSE
ITSELF AND ALL THE FOLKS LIVING
THERE?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK IT WAS
KAYLEE IN PARTICULAR.
THERE'S OTHER DETAILS THAT WILL
COME OUT LATER ON, BUT I'VE
ALWAYS SAID THIS TO MADDY'S
MOTHER AND HER FATHER THAT DOES
IT REALLY MATTER?
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE IN THE CASE IT DOES, BUT
TO US NONE OF THESE GIRLS
DESERVED THIS.
I DON'T WANT A PARENT TO THINK
THAT -- YOU KNOW, TO FEEL EVEN
WORSE WHEN YOU GO THROUGH THIS
TO THINK THAT, OH, MY GIRL SAID
SOMETHING THAT CAUGHT HIM OFF
GUARD AND THEN THESE OTHER
PEOPLE ARE JUST A PART OF THAT.
THAT'S A CANCER INSIDE YOU AND
I'M NOT GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN.
I'M GOING TO TRY TO KEEP MY
FAMILY FROM THINKING ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
THE REAL PROBLEM WE HAVE IS WE
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL THAT THOUGHT
IT WAS OKAY TO, YOU KNOW, ATTACK
OTHER HUMAN BEINGS.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO FOCUS
ON.
>> OF COURSE.
AND THEN THAT'S GOT TO BE JUST A
BRUTAL THOUGHT TO LIVE WITH.
WAS THERE ANY SENSE -- HAVE YOU
BEEN TOLD IF THERE WAS ANY
CONTACT BETWEEN KOHBERGER AND
THEM PRIOR TO THIS, OR WAS HE
JUST SURVEILLING THEM FROM AFAR?
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY PINPOINT
INFORMATION THAT I CAN SHARE
THAT WOULD SAY THAT THEY WERE
DIRECTLY IN CONTACT.
THERE'S DEFINITELY RUMOR MILLS
OUT THERE THAT SAY THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE INFORMATION.
WE CAN ALMOST GUARANTEE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE MORE DETAILS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE BROUGHT IN.
I WOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
SURPRISED IF THERE WASN'T A
CLEAR TOUCH POINT THAT WOULD
SUGGEST THAT HE WAS INTERESTED
IN ONE OR TWO OF THE PEOPLE MORE
THAN HE WAS THE OTHERS, BUT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WE HAVE -- WE
HAVE ENOUGH IN THAT AFFIDAVIT TO
BELIEVE THAT THIS DEFENDANT HAS
A LOT TO EXPLAIN.
>> YEAH.
NO QUESTION.
HE'S OF COURSE INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY, NATURE OF OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
>> I AGREE.
>> HAVE INVESTIGATORS SHARED
WITH YOU ANY INDICATION AS TO A
POSSIBLE MOTIVE?
>> NO, WE HAVEN'T GOT DOWN
THAT -- I KNOW THAT I'M SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING AN INTERVIEW WITH
THEM, SHANNON IS PUTTING THAT
TOGETHER AND COORDINATING THAT.
SO THAT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT
COMES UP, BUT THEY'RE VERY
CAREFUL AND I'VE TOLD THEM DON'T
TELL ME SOMETHING THAT PUTS ME
IN A SITUATION WHERE I MAY
DISCLOSE SOMETHING THAT COULD
HURT THE CASE.
>> ALSO IN THE AFFIDAVIT IT SAYS
THAT THE ROOMMATE, SURVIVING
ROOMMATE, IDENTIFIED JUST BY THE
KMIS
INITIALS DM. SAYS SHE HEARD
CRYING COMING FROM ONE OF THE
ROOMS, SAW A MAN DRESSED IN
BLACK WITH A MASK ON WALK PAST
HERE.
DO WE KNOW WHY POLICE WERE NOT
CALLED UNTIL SEVERAL HOURS AFTER
THAT?
S>> WE DON'T HAVE THOSE DETAILS.
I DO KNOW THAT SHE WAS PETRIFIED
AND I THINK PEOPLE RESPOND A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
I DON'T WANT TO MAKE HER A
VICTIM AND I DON'T -- PEOPLE ARE
MEAN, THEY WILL GO AFTER PEOPLE
AND I SAY DON'T DO IT, MY NAME,
MY FAMILY NAME.
I THINK SHE WAS JUST SCARED.
VERY SCARED AND IT'S NOT LIKE
WHERE EVERYONE BEHAVES LIKE
PEOPLE THINK THEY WOULD.
EVENTUALLY WE WILL GET ALL THE
DETAILS AND WE WILL UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> I GET IT.
>> IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE --
>> PETRIFIED IS THE RIGHT WORD,
I CAN UNDERSTAND.
I DO WANT TO ASK YOU BEFORE WE
GO YOU WERE IN COURT, YOU HAD
THE CHANCE TO SEE KOHBERGER,
PERHAPS TO LOOK HIM IN THE EYES.
WHAT WERE YOU FEELING AT THAT
MOMENT?
>> I WAS PRETTY ANGRY.
I WAS PRETTY HEATED.
I WANTED HIM TO LOOK ME IN THE
EYE.
HE KNOWS I WANT HIM TO LOOK ME
IN THE EYE SO HE'S -- HE DIDN'T.
HE DIDN'T GIVE ME THAT
OPPORTUNITY WHEN HE WAS BACK IN
HIS HOME STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA,
HE DID TURN AROUND AND LOOK FOR
HIS PARENTS AND NOT ME, HE
DIDN'T GIVE ME THAT.
SO I THINK HE UNDERSTANDS THAT
I'M NOT GOING TO SEE SOMETHING
IN HIS EYES THAT I WANT TO SEE,
YOU KNOW.
I WANT TO SEE AN INNOCENT MAN,
BUT I FEEL LIKE HE'S SCARED TO
LOOK AT ME IN THE EYES AND START
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S ABOUT TO
HAPPEN TO HIM.
YOU KNOW, HE PICKED THE WRONG
FAMILY AND I'M NOT SCARED OF A
CONFLICT AND WE'RE NOT SCARED --
WE'RE NOT RUNNING.
WE ARE COMING AT HIM AND THE
DEFENDANT HAS HIS HANDS FULL.
>> DID YOU SENSE ANYTHING FROM
HIM, ANY EMOTION IN THAT MOMENT,
IN THAT COURTROOM?
>> I DID.
I SENSED SOMEBODY SHOCKED AND
SCARED AND NOT PREPARED.
LIKE ALMOST LIKE THIS IS NOTHING
LIKE I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE.
SO HIS MANNERISMS, HIS BODY
LANGUAGE -- I'M PRETTY IN TUNE
WITH CERTAIN GUYS, I PLAYED
SPORTS MY WHOLE LIFE, I'VE BEEN
IN DIFFERENT GYMS, I'VE BEEN IN
CONFERENCE ROOMS WITH WHITE
COLLAR.
I CAN SENSE CONFIDENCE AND I DID
NOT SENSE THAT AT ALL.
I SENSED SOMEBODY WHO WAS
FLARING, SCARED AND WORRIED.
>> I TELL YOU, ERICA, I'VE BEEN
SPEAKING WITH STEVE FOR A NUMBER
OF WEEKS NOW AND I SENSE -- YOU
COULD SEE IT THERE, YOU SENSE
EXHAUSTION.
OF COURSE, WE WOULD BE HAVING
LOST A CHILD THAT WAY, BUT ALSO
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME I SENSED
REALLY MORE RESOLVE THERE.
I THINK WHAT CAME ACROSS TO ME
IS YOU HEARD HIM SAY THERE, HE
PICKED THE WRONG FAMILY.
THE SUSPECT PICKED THE WRONG
FAMILY.
THAT THERE IS A PATH TO JUSTICE
HERE, RIGHT, THAT HE WAS
EXPRESSING, BUT STILL
HEARTBREAK.
THE WAY HE DESCRIBED IT, THAT
HIS VIEW IS THAT THIS GUY WAS
HUNTING -- HUNTING THOSE
VICTIMS.
>> AND TO HEAR HIM TALK ABOUT,
YOU KNOW -- WE KNOW AS PARENTS,
BUT TO IMAGINE AS A PARENT TO
HEAR HIM SAY MY DAUGHTER HAD HER
PHONE RIGHT THERE AND SHE
COULDN'T EVEN CALL 911.
HOW HELPLESS HE MUST FEEL.
I WAS ALSO JUST REALLY STRUCK BY
HIS EMPATHY AND HIS GRACE AND I
THINK, AGAIN, JUST A TESTAMENT
TO HIM AS A PARENT.
WHEN YOU ASKED HIM THE QUESTION
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT THE
ROOMMATE WHO ACCORDING TO THE
AFFIDAVIT WAS HOME, SAW THE --
WHO WE BELIEVE WAS THE SUSPECT,
RIGHT, BUT THEN THERE WERE NO
CALLS FOR EIGHT HOURS AND HIM
JUST SAYING, LOOK, THIS IS NOT A
MOVIE.
THIS IS JUST, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE
TO TRY TO PUT YOURSELF IN THAT
MOMENT.
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK IT JUST SPEAKS TO --
SPEAKS TO WHO HE IS.
>> GOOD FOR HIM FOR SAYING THAT.
AS HE SAID, PETRIFIED.
THIS IS A GIRL JUST OUT OF HER
TEENAGE YEARS WHO WITNESSED --
JUST YOU CAN IMAGINE THE FEAR IN
THAT MOMENT.
ANYWAY, WE WILL KEEP ON THE
STORY.
A LOT MORE TO COME.